tonight a lot of business owners in
southern nevada are worried about the
extended pause
the coped spike keeps the paws in place
and the pause
keeps capacity restrictions in place and
that keeps money from coming in as it
should
sasha loftus filed this report before
heading to breaking news we're looking
to keep these measures in place for
another 30 days
it was news no one wanted to hear it
really makes it tough we're losing you
know like 10 to 20 grand
per month governor siselek announced
another
extension of nevada's statewide pause
monday as our coving case
hospitalization and death rates continue
to soar
it means a continued 25 percent capacity
limit
for places like gyms and restaurants
we're banding together and we're helping
each other
figure out all of these extra processes
that we need to go through just to keep
our businesses afloat
julie johnston of rhino gym and local
restaurant owners tabitha and john
simmons say the financial burden
has been tough to bear restaurants make
such a small amount of money as it is
so no restaurant is going to survive and
make money on 50
they're just let survive and they're
definitely going to lose money at 25
that's why they're asking everyone to go
along with current health guidelines
we are definitely following all the
rules and where you can see that we're
wearing our mask
so they can stay afloat and welcome
customers
back safely let's get through this so we
can get back
the statewide pause is now expected to
continue until mid-february but
governor siselek said if the numbers do
improve significantly before then
he will of course re-evaluate and
announce potential changes accordingly